Is a 31 year old personal trainer from Kansas.
He is a former professional football player and he has been married for over two
years.
He was asked over 50 questions by our polygraph examiner.
21 of those questions have been chosen to me.
Tyack this is your moment of the truth
and how you feeling little nervous, but you know, I'm ready to win some money.
Let's take a moment to see who's come here tonight to hear you tell.
The truth. He's got that Johnny Bravo head. Mm.
Remember Johnny Bravo mm-hmm <affirmative> Johnny Bravo might have been the
coolest cartoon character who never got laid. And you know what?
It makes me kind of sad.
Cause there was a couple episodes where I'm like this man deserved it.
But the show riders were always right in the way that this never got.
He never got late. Johnny Bravo deserves some in cartoon.
Yes.
I'm co Ty's wife. I'm April Ty's friend.
Ty's friend, question five.
Do you think you're the best looking of all your friends?
The question could have been phrased as, do you have a big ego
ready to admit it to America for $2,000?
Oh
yes.
You really think you're better looking the Marette mean he's got a great smile.
Constellation prize. Yeah. What's that?
All right, here we go. Question six. As a football player,
did you ever sneak a peek at another player's privates
while taking a shot?
See, this sounds so taboo. If we're being honest,
if you ever been in a male locker room,
every has looked at somebody else's Dick at one point or another,
especially if you go to a gym with old people. Yeah.
I don't know what it is about you old. You just, it's not a peak y'all.
Wanna expose that. Hey, what's that? Jerry? You good?
What did you do in the weekend? I know.
And I'm sitting there trying to go to my locker. These. Hey,
my only issue is when I'm sitting, I'm my locker and I'm trying to open it.
And this man's like good day young.
<laugh> trying to have a whole conversation and it is like, whoa, Jesus cry.
I was just trying to get and you know what bag over there.
So my experience it's mostly old white dudes.
Yeah. Yeah. Why be you gonna have to hold L this one? Yep, yep, yep. Yep.
Man, buddy. How you doing? Like what the are you doing bro? Yeah. Hey Jerry,
I see you out there. Yeah. Okay. Get dressed. Listen.
I don't know what lady's washrooms are like,
but men's washrooms are not private. They're anything but private. Jesus.
You see a lot of private parts, but I would not consider them private.
I have never. And listen, if you're going look at another man's Dick.
It's not gay as long you say pause afterwards. It's fine. <laugh> okay.
Me personally, when I leave a shower,
but pause <laugh> mom's just minding my business.
I'm just doing my. Mm-hmm <affirmative> that be Ugh.
It's the old mother. It's the old people. It's the old ones.
I don't know what it is up with them. Ha I don't care.
Jerry. Am I gonna impress? You know what I mean? I do be laughing sometimes.
Cuz sometimes you see,
you see someone drop a soap in the washroom and even though nothing's gonna
happen, there's always a thought in my head of like, that's gay Nick. <laugh>
what? When bends down to he bends down, he bends out. He drops. He drops a soap.
It's like, huh? Look, I drop my so hold on. Listen. Let me there,
there there's dudes. Whoop. That's so slippery. Look. Oh. There it go again.
Whoop. <laugh> Hey, I'm just trying to go to my locker, sir.
Can you just kick it over there. There's one.
So the way this <laugh> the way this shower area was set up, it's like,
it was like a rectangle and there's one entrance right here. Okay.
There's a rectangles over here.
The entrance is there and then there's a bunch of seats and lockers over here.
So I'm sitting there and my homie goes into the washroom first to go to go
shower.
Right? He goes in and he comes right back. What wrong? I was like, man,
nevermind. And I was like, what? So I get up to go shower. Cause I'm like,
that was weird. And I go in <laugh>
and the way the showers, the showers are all around the square. Right?
There's a right in the middle showering.
But he's got the water hitting his back and he's just staring towards the
entrance. Just
he's just cleaning big. Right. And I walked in and I went,
whoa, wait, what is he doing? He was just this. How was hitting his pants?
But the way he was standing at the entrance, he was like just cleaning himself.
And I don't know what it did.
It gave no, it gave me please Johnson vibes.
He didn't say nothing. But what I heard when he was just like this, he went,
I like you and I want you and I'm going, have you, so Hey,
I pulled the N Flanders. His.
I walk in and out <laugh> I said, Nick, I'm a shower home.
<laugh> not having shower home. Nobody getting in my booty at that time.
Question seven,
If Kaia developed a flabby stomach, but you encourage her to get life.
It's like, I'd encourage myself to get <laugh> the,
you have to imagine he's a personal trainer. So there's probably extra, uh,
pressure on her. Yeah. To maintain beauty standards.
Yeah. Because she's like, she sees who he's training.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> and he's at the gym all the time.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> yeah.
Yes.
Yo laughing after you say something up. Doesn't make it. Okay. Yes. <laugh>.
True.
Anything you wanna say? Yeah. I thought you'd say no.
How well does your wife get along with your friends? Depends.
On the situation, but it's pretty good.
When these ask these questions, they already know the answers.
Of course they do.
So the way that they're setting up every question is that they have an angle.
How they want to make you look, if you truthfully, so they're like,
you gonna get this money. Yeah. Yeah. You gonna get, but you going pay? Oh yeah.
You, yeah. They'll be like, do you love your wife? They're like, I was like,
yeah. It's like, cool.
Have there ever in times where you thought about dis enforcing your wife play.
Yes. Why would you lead with that question? But these pieces of,
producers are just like,
how do you feel about interracial marriage? Well, you know,
I'm supportive of all races getting married. Right?
Dude's got a white wife and they're like, Craig,
have you ever thought about leaving your wife for a black woman? It's like,
oh my God, the way they lead into the question.
Question eight.
Have you ever suspected one of your friends of making a play for cocktail?
This is, he said, no, you see the way they sit up the, you know what?
This is like, this is what,
like when you were a teenager and you went out and you,
you come I'm back home and your mom like, so where were you tonight? No one,
well, she already knows. Knows. She just wants to see.
You go lie to me so that she be like, so where were you tonight? Like up.
Oh yeah. I'm just hanging out. Tim's Tim's huh? Tim's huh?
So why did Sandra's mom say that? Sandra saw you at the club tonight?
What do you get by your parents? God. At that point,
they doing the most and guess what? When I get kids and I catch them. Yeah.
I'm gonna do the most, you know, what's even worse when there's an audience.
Yep. Your uncles, your siblings. When your sister's looking at you,
like you up. Ooh. Ooh. My little sister was such a piece.
Sometimes she'd go get the weapon that my mom was gonna use before she even
asked. I said, who asked you?
Yes. That answer.
Yeah. Yo I I'm suspecting. It's the editing. Yo.
Cause the you're making the black dude to be out like the ones trying to the
white. Yeah. Yeah.
Sus SU does he know maybe the.
Question nine?
Have you ever had sexual relations with someone the very same day you met her?
<Laugh>.
Yo, that's not a friend. That's a witness. That's not a, as a witness.
You, you, you, when a girlfriend conflicts,
a boyfriend and the boys were sitting around and looking like
that is guilty. Then if, if, if a girl calls us like,
so is it true that you Melina before we were dating? And the guy's like,
well, ah.
Question 11. Since you've been married,
have you used the internet to flirt with other women?
No.
To 12.
Do you think you've delayed having children?
Because you're not sure if Kaia will be your life long part.
I need your.
Answer is yes.
True.
These are the best producers I may have ever seen.
The way they set up the previous one to make him look good.
Like have you ever flowed with most people were accepting. Yes. He's like, no,
I've never done that. Like, oh, he's a good guy. Next one's gonna be a though.
Got that. Can't be great to hear April. What did you say to KA?
I asked her if, um, hearing this worth a hundred.
Thousand dollars question 13
as a personal trainer,
have you touched a female client or that was required of you?
This one could end careers. Oh, careers,
relationships.
No, That answer is
like,
no, Ty,
I'm so sorry.
You, you know what I noticed about this guy's head,
he seems like the type of person who would finish killing his whole family and
smile. Like it seems like to mask any emotion that he's feeling.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> this man just smiles and laughs it's weird.
He just got caught about this. He's like,
there's a weirdness to their face TV. What is it? TV makes you make weird.
You have to keep your face up. So you feel like you have to, you know,
act a certain way in front of that TV.
Not to lose for I'm laughing about it.
And it's oftentimes laughing about this is this is, this is nothing.
This is not crushing me. You know, just to, I agree.
My thing is when you come to TV,
sometimes you look uncomfortable rather than you look deceptive.
He does not look uncomfortable to me. He looks deceptive.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> right. Meaning he'll say something that he knows is wrong.
Angel, don't laugh to mask it to me. There's not a TV thing.
It looks like an everyday life thing. Do you get what I'm saying? Yeah. I bad.
I wouldn't know because I didn't speak to the guy like that and I don't know the
guy like that, but I see what you're saying. Yeah. The same way.
Like when she does this, I don't know. That's a TV thing.
I think that's probably no, that that's nervous. Yeah. That's what I'm saying.
Right. So I feel she did it a couple times.
He did it the whole time where he was just laughing and smiling through every
yeah. That's right. So that's why I'm just like, there's a weird to his face.
Like, like the emotion doesn't match the moment. If that makes sense.
You get what I'm saying? Yeah. But anyways, where'd you get it too deep into it,
but me watching that, I'm just like, bruh, you went on TV.
Didn't make no money and may have up your career. Ain't your relationship?
Crazy. This show was cold
goed. Yeah. It it, yeah. Okay. It was crazy. Yeah.
My sister was watching that show when it was on on it's a good show.
It didn't last low. It's a good show. It didn't last long. It's a good show.
Let us know what you're asking in. The comments of love. Wanna hear from you.